[Applaus]
[Musik]
transparency international hat wie jedes
jahr den drückten corruption perception
index veröffentlicht das ranking über
die am meisten und am wenigsten gruppen
ländern der welt wir sprechen hier über
die creme de la creme der korruptions
magix in deren folge hat sich seit dem
letzten jahr kaum etwas geändert denn
natürlich ändern sich korrupte systeme
nicht über nacht schon gar nicht mitten
in einer pandemie welche alle augen der
öffentlichkeit auf sich zieht korrupten
politikern kommt eine solche pandemie
aber nicht nur deswegen gelegen weil die
aufmerksamkeit der bürger durch sie
abgelenkt wird und sie unter dem
deckmantel des notstands allerlei schon
abseits der gewöhnlichen gültigen
kontrollmechanismen treiben können nein
sie missbrauchen die solche auch um die
bevölkerung zu spalten ihre eigenen
anhänger fest da hinter sich zu scharen
und kritiker abzuschneiden
politisch medial gesellschaftlich er gab
es in die familien hinein zwietracht zu
säen deswegen legt wir unseren fokus in
diesem video darauf die korruption im
schatten der pandemie ein ganzes land in
die knie zwingen kann und danach die
folgen von naturkatastrophen unternehmen
noch gravierender macht während sich
einige skrupellose menschen mit hilfe
des corona virus beim plündern der
staatskassen eine goldene nase verdienen
also könnt ihr euch noch erinnern welche
länder letztes jahr an der spitze des
corruption perception entstanden und
umgekehrt welche am wenigsten korrupt
waren so oder so wir geben dir einfach
mal ein blitzschnelles update für das
jahr 2020
[Musik]
eine option in der welt vor 2020
letztes jahr haben wir schon vermittelt
das ist noch viel zu tun gibt was
korruptionsbekämpfung angeht und kaum
ein grund zur freude besteht immerhin
schon zwei drittel aller länder kläglich
an dieser herausforderung
aus alldem es gibt gewinner und
verlierer laut transparency
international sind die fünf korruptesten
länder der welt eben diesem jahr
glas wird wenn es zu egal welches schon
nahe dran ist bald die nummer eins zu
werden
jammer liegen zuschauer kaum zu glauben
aber selbst marlboro schafft es mit
seinem klub und durch gruppen und
repressiven regime noch nicht bist
kannst noch um wir sind jedoch recht
zuversichtlich dass sind das in zukunft
gelingen könnte
mehr dazu in einem künftigen video vor
venezuela thronen dann der jemen syrien
zu malia und final des südsudan
derselben funktion vom letzten jahr
am anderen ende der rangliste befindet
sich die vertrauenswürdigsten länder der
welt welche alle mit 85 punkten
beeindrucken die schweiz schweden
singapur und finnland darüber liegen nur
noch punktgleich dänemark und neuseeland
überraschend gut so richtig ehrlich
nicht nach religion ist ob dirk sieht es
wie folgt aus in der asien pazifik
region führen und auf seeland singapur
und australien die korruptesten sind
kambodscha afghanistan und nordkorea in
zentralasien und den nachfolgestaaten
der sowjetunion schneidet praktisch
bundesland sehr schlecht ab aus allem es
gibt bessere und schlechtere beispiele
georgien armenien und weißrussland die
drei am wenigsten korrupten länder
dieser region aber auch das beste
georgien schlägt du ganz knapp die 50
punkte marke
denn in zentralasien ist das grob sein
eigentlich schon ein volkssport die
besten klicken stellen dort pakistan
turkmenistan und tadschikistan
wer dorthin kommt und nicht ordentlich
die scheine ab drückt das ist quasi eine
lokal
tradition
aber gut bei text die siege im nahen
osten und nordafrika sind die emirate
und katar
die fels text dort sind syrien der jemen
und libyen mit einem besonders
unterirdischen ergebnis tja wer hätte
das erwartet
anderswo ist war unerwartet durchaus
gute nachrichten in den teilen afrikas
südlich der sahara steigt ganze fünf
länder durchaus passable nämlich die
seychellen kap verde und mauritius und
erstaunlicherweise auch botswana und
wonder die schlechtesten noten erhalten
hier wirst du dazu malia und das
südsudan übrigens der jüngste staat der
welt europa als region ist hingegen im
vergleich eine bastion der
korruptionsbekämpfung an dessen spitze
die skandinavischen länder drohnen ein
wenig enttäuschender ist die
balkanregion ländlich ungarn rumänien
und bulgarien
schlussendlich kommt sitzungen gesamt
amerikanischen kontinent wie erwartet
führen kanada und die usa
die schlechte nachricht lautet aber fast
alle lateinamerikanischen länder
scheitern kläglich aber auch hier gibt
es ausnahmen
lichtblick gebilde 03 schiri costa rica
und einige karibischen insgesamt hat er
es aber mit einer region zu tun die
aufgeladen ist mit jeder menge politik
plänen hoffnungen und widersprechen
so liebe zuschauer und jetzt kommt die
stunde der wahrheit denn unsere große
frage heute lautet ja keinen korruption
den untergang eines ganzen landes ein
willkommen in rund durch
[Musik]
durch korruption verwüstet als ich dann
gesehen ist honduras in lateinamerika
noch nicht mal am schlimmsten dran
zumindest im vergleich mit dem charakter
haiti und venezuela
es illustriert aber hervorragend wie
sich ein land schleichend jahr für jahr
im ranking verschlechtern kann und dann
im krisenjahr 2020 total unter die räder
kommt und zwar wie kein zweites land wir
sprechen hier von enormer
institutioneller erosion
zur veranschaulichung in diesem land
entwickelt sich die korruption zu einem
so kam es dass sie das land in einem
feld verwandeln kann
ein wirtschaftlich zurückgebliebenes
land in dem sich gewalt und politische
missstände wie ein lauffeuer ausbreiten
korruption könnte in honduras
mittlerweile der größte
wirtschaftsfaktor sein doch so nicht und
dann zeigen wir die harten fakten zu
dieser tragischen entwicklung also was
jetzt gut aus korruption in honduras
verschlingt 12,5 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts 12,5 prozent des
bip von duras im jahr 2018 wurden durch
korruption in ihren verschiedensten
formen absorbiert so eine ausstellung
die organisation des anti korruptions
netzwerks vorgestellt wurde
wir sprechen hier über einen umfang von
fast drei milliarden dollar in einem
land das bereits zu den ärmsten ländern
lateinamerikas gehört ein land in dem
2020 den menschen nichts anderes als
tragödie
schmerz und offene türen für korruption
brachte
und wenn ich von offene türen rede dann
meine ich das nicht als metapher
in 2020 hat der honduranische präsident
juan orlando hat sich dazu entschieden
das mandat für cch nicht zu verlängern
aber was ist ma zte h das ist eine
organisation der amerikanischen staaten
mit der mission und duras im kampf gegen
korruption und straflosigkeit zu
unterstützen im jahr 2016 gegründet hat
sie schon sage und schreibe 14
untersuchungen gegen 133 personen
eingeleitet welche auch hohe mitglieder
der regierung und des kongresses
betreibt die untersuchung namens
operation pandora ist ein musterbeispiel
dafür wie 38 hochrangige politiker und
beamte millionen dollar welche für die
landwirtschaft gedacht waren abzweigten
raus aus dem staatshaushalt rein in die
parteikassen uns natürlich auch in die
eigenen taschen
seit der gründung von match2blue führt
welche es den gruppierten stück für
stück schwerer machten den staat
auszuplündern diese erfolge haben eine
so sehr gestört dass der präsident des
landes die organisation ein fachverband
erst war aber nur ein symptom das
schlimmste kommt noch 2020 wartet eine
reihe von gesetzlichen änderungen mit
sich welche größere freiheiten bei der
rechtlichen auslegung von korruption
einräumen natürlich alles sehr angenehm
für die korrumpierten glaube du hast
dich nicht gehört sie haben korruption
wirklich einfach realisiert im juli 2020
tat eine änderung im strafgesetzbuch in
kraft die unter anderem das strafmaß für
drogenhandel schmuggel für trug gegen
öffentlich verwaltung oder veruntreuung
öffentlicher gelder reduziert es gab den
vorschlag bei korruptionsfällen
gefängnisstrafen durch andere weniger
restriktive strafen zu ersetzen wenn er
angeklagte zu weniger als fünf jahren
verurteilt und das geld zurückgezahlt
wird und hat in mutters also immer eine
du kommst aus dem gefängnis frei karte
welche man nur benutzen muss wenn der
plan auf liegt man gibt einfach das geld
zurück und startet wieder auf los aber
auch das ist nur die spitze des eisbergs
die strafrechtliche verantwortlichkeit
juristische personen wird ausgeklammert
und sie wissen wie bestimmte unternehmen
irgendwas agieren es gibt zahlreiche
unternehmen die beziehungen zum staat
unterhalten und dass es hier bald keine
strafrechtliche verantwortlichkeit gibt
das ist viel zu wünschen übrig
gleichzeitig hat diese reform des
strafgesetzbuches natürlich auf die
vorhandenen optionen der medien
eingeschränkt mit denen sich die option
spiel aufdecken der intransparenz gehört
einfach zum einmaleins der korruption
diese reform ist bereits in kraft
getreten ach ja und zufälligerweise sind
viele der kongressabgeordneten die idee
zugestimmt haben auch in ställe mit dem
justizministerium vermittelt ich will
hier aber gar nicht über diesen das
zufälligen zusammen noch anrichten das
ist könnt ihr seid ja und selbst der
präsident von honduras ist von us
bundesanwälten beschuldigt worden
drogengelder erhalten zu haben um seine
politische karriere zu zahlen und eben
dieser entschied sich dazu im atp aus
dem land zu schmeißen all dies ist mit
einer strategie verbunden einen
systematischen prozess der vom kongress
und der exekutive ausgeht diese haben
bereits schwach institutionen die gegen
verbrechen vorgehen insbesondere gegen
korruption und drogenhandel noch weiter
geschwächt das land ist ja bereits
durchzogen von korruption
eine studie ergab dass vitamin b und
gute beziehungen zu der regierenden
partei als die wichtigsten
einstellungskriterien öffentliche dienst
wahrgenommen werden in der tat ist
bekannt dass unter den mehr als 220.000
bürokraten in der koreanischen regierung
viele von politikern hand verlesen
wurden
und die dürften natürlich klar sein dass
die persönliche auswahl dafür sorgt dass
die gewählten angestellten sehr loyal
sind die regierende partei in honduras
ist so korrupt dass man es eben schon
als wahlversprechen ansehen kann aktiv
noch korrupte strukturen zu schauen und
selbstverständlich handelt es sich nur
um ein offenes geheimnis dass die
regierung weitreichende verbindungen zum
organisierten drogenhandel unterhält
hier einige beispiele dafür der sohn des
ehemaligen präsidenten fabio logo es ist
momentan für 24 jahre im gefängnis und
ein gericht in new york hat auch den
bruder des präsidenten in mehreren
anklagepunkten schuldig gesprochen er
war teil eines plans ein böses weißes
pulver in die vereinigten staaten
einzuführen
ich glaube dass wir beide wissen dass er
da kein zucker einzelnen wollte der
präsident ist nationalkongresses
honduras murisier oliva hat auch
verbindungen zu drogenkartellen gegen
den bürgermeister von tegucigalpa dass
die assura gleichzeitig auch
präsidentschaftskandidat steht ebenfalls
korruptionsvorwürfe im raum aber im
vergleich zu diesen kleinen fischen
spiel der präsident in einer ganz
anderen liga als ob ein kreisligist
gegen ein bundesliga team antritt
us bundesanwälte beschuldigen den
honorar mission präsidenten der direkten
verbindungen mit mehreren toten
er hat schmiergeld angenommen im
austausch für jetzt nicht erschrecken
militärische unterstützung der karte
operation und seinen gesamten wahlkampf
hat er mit mitteln der koranischen
sozialversicherungen querfinanziert
genau in einem der sowieso schon ärmsten
länder in lateinamerika schade haben die
honduraner als 300 millionen dollar
weniger für ihre vorsorge minister weil
sie nicht für den staat arbeiten die
beweise die das justizministerium in
diesem fall und anderen fällen gesammelt
hat lassen neue fragen über die
hochrangigen beamten der regierung
aufkommen auch über den amtierenden
präsidenten der ein wichtiger
verbündeter der usa ist diese beamten
erhalten millionen dollar von
menschenhändlern um kampagnen zu
finanzieren und ihre macht zu festigen
das krisenjahr 2020 das auf eine
beeindruckende art und weise gezeigt wie
so ein schleichender prozess der
korrumpierung zu einem riesigen knall
führen kann und ist sicherlich das ist
auch schon wieder eine übertreibung nun
ich glaube du wirst erstaunt sein von
denen sich jetzt auf drohungen abgründen
tragödien und gewalt
außer der vorher stellen korruption
wachst du das jahr 2020 neben den
crooner wir uns noch zwei besondere
geschenke zwei hurricanes von herden
ausmaßen wüteten durch das land 1000
honduraner wurden obdachlos und noch
mehr verloren den zugang zu
grundlegender versorgung
doch unabhängig vom leid ausgelöst durch
diese katastrophen gab es doch einige
findige geschäftemacher welche darin
eine goldgrube entdeckten je eine kleine
anekdote zu einem dieser geschäftsmänner
nach dem ausbruch der korona band in die
im jahr 2020 hat die regierung als eine
maßnahme beschlossen ihre kapazitäten im
gesundheitswesen aufzustocken
dieser auftrag wurde vom damaligen
geschäftsführer der investitions agentur
marco kran an land gezogen wo kran
sollte den kauf und transport von sieben
weltcup häusern durchführt diese sollten
mit 150 betten bereit stellen zusammen
mit der dazugehörigen
intensivmedizinischen ausrüstung weg gut
oder nächste mal du solltest das musst
du hier inzwischen kennen die dinge
liegen natürlich auch hier im eigenen
programm hat eine firma damit beauftragt
deren geschäftsadresse ein gps
briefkasten in orlando florida ist diese
firma sollte will betrag von 50
millionen dollar
die krankenhäuser geschaffen nun eine
solche summe wäre für deutschland oder
einen jetzt sparen nur kleingeld für
honduras aber ein stattliches sümmchen
zu diesem zeitpunkt gab es noch keinen
vertrag
circa 47 millionen dollar wurden aber
bereits bezahlt zusätzlich muss man hier
erwähnen dass diese summe bereits um
etwa 12 bis 16 millionen dollar höher
liegt als marktüblich und damit kann
sich entspannen auch ganz gut aus so und
jetzt rate was danach passiert ist also
danach alles perfekt geklappt innerhalb
kürzester zeit wurde alles liefert und
man konnte vielen menschen das leben
retten wo kran hat einen tollen job
gemacht und ist zum nationalhelden
aufgestiegen ende gut alles gut
so hätte der letzte teil unserer
anekdote ablaufen können wenn wir nicht
ins toraus wehren und dieses video einen
ganz anderen titel hätte eigentlich
sollte man ja meinen dass dies alles
eine zeitkritische auftrag sei aus
dessen kamen die ersten beiden
vertrackten häuser erst mehr als vier
monate später an einwandfrei eindeutig
nicht sie waren beschädigt und hatten
keine
ohne ausrüstung dabei mit anderen worten
und durchaus bezahlt dafür fällt
krankenhäuser viel geld und hat die zu
spät zwei gebrauchte zelten
und jetzt haltet euch fest der verkäufer
dieser fällt krankenhäuser heißt axel
lux und ist autor er hat ein buch
geschrieben über geschäftspraktiken in
lateinamerika und die man am besten
bestechungsgelder zahlt einzelfall also
gar nicht nächste story diverse
organisation entdeckten überteuerte
verträge für den erwerb von
medizinischer ausrüstung die in der
krise besonders wichtig wäre zb datums
geräte aber wenn die aufträge der
überteuert gewesen wären in einigen
fällen wurde noch nicht einmal geliefert
und das hat nicht nur geld gekostet
sondern nachweisbar auch menschenleben
ein widerwärtiges abschwungs mutiges
verhalten welches einem die direkten
schäden von korruption vor augen führt
und vergesst nicht alles nur des
schnöden mammons leben und bei erst den
eindruck hat wir wären schon ganz tief
drin im kaninchenbau denen kann ich
versichern dass wir uns erst am anfang
befinden die weit verbreitete korruption
hat schleichend an der stabilität vieler
wichtiger institutionen gefressen und zu
ihrer version geführt die bürger haben
kein vertrauen mehr sind aber die tanks
geworden
diese erosion verstärkt durch das
krisenjahr 2020 begünstigt auch ein
anderer prozess die verwandlung des
ganzen landes in einem gänzlich von
kartellen kontrollierten stadt und all
das bekommt die bürger mittlerweile
hautnah zu spüren die gewalt in honduras
nimmt täglich zu
und die koka pflanze zu dem was der
löwen zahlen der deutschen landschaft
ist und du hast ist also wie ihr seht
auf dem besten weg ein neues nicht
league und klub der typischen failed
state zu werden und das sozusagen vor
unseren augen nur falls ihr euch schon
mal gefragt habt die ist sowas
eigentlich überhaupt kommen kann also
dies war die traurige geschichte eines
armen lateinamerikanischen landes
welches von korruption duell
verschlungen wird
nun kommt aber meine frage an dich
kannst du hast deine meinung nach noch
etwas zumal das zu überwinden oder ist
es schon so spät wie sieht es in deinem
land aus hat die korona krise die
maßstäbe in sachen korruption
verschrieben was meint ihr
schreibt uns bitte eure meinung in die
kommentare unter diesem video denn wir
immer sind sehr oft diese schon sehr
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
video gefallen und auch etwas gebracht
hat was ja gibt uns bitte ein leck und
unterstützt uns in denen ihr dieses
video mit euren freunden teilt es gut
und bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]